لدي بعض الأسئلة عن القرآن,تعليقا على سورة رقم 4
نعم
- لماذا يقال أن الرجال,الأولاد يأخذون ضعف ميراث النساء
- هذا ليس في سورة 4 بل سورة 2
في سورة 2 أيضا ,سورة البقرة
لكن لا بد أنها في موضع ما في سورة 4 أيضا
و
حسنا, المغزى هو..
انها لا تقول النصف على فكرة,حسنا, لأنه اذا قمت بحساب النسب, اذا قمت بحساب النسب
الرجل مسؤول عن نفقة السيدات في المنزل, سواء كانت الأم
زوجة  أو ابنة أو
أخت, لهذا اذا ورث الرجل من أبيه يجب عليه أن يطعم "ينفق" من حصته
أمه
اخته , زوجته و بناته . حسنا؟ اذن هو يتقاسم حصته. من الناحية الأخرى..
مهما كان ما ترثه النساء
من المتوفي
- الزوجة تحتفظ بحصتها لنفسها - نعم
- الأم تحتفظ بحصتها, البنات يحتفظن بحصصهن
لا يتوجب عليهن انفاق فلس واحد من حصصهن. انها مسؤولية الرجل. لذلك كانت الحكمة
أن يأخذ الرجال حصة زائدة حتى يتمكنوا من اعالة العائلة و ان يستمروا في اعالة العائلة لأنها مسؤوليتهم هم
الانفاق على العائلة. من وجهة النظر الاسلامية
هل تعرف أنه
في سورة النساء, سنقوم بتحليلها, حسنا؟ على سبيل المثال الأشخاص الذين يرثون 50%
حسنا الأشخاص الذين يرثون 50% هم الزوج, اذا لم يكن هناك زوجا
فمن ترث هي الابنة ,الحفيدة,الأخت الشقيقة,الأخت من الأب
هذا يعني 4 نساء يرثن اكثر من رجل واحد في هذه الحالة..و الأمر سيصبح أفضل
66.7% من يرث...
أي من يرث ثلثين,حسنا, اذا كان الابن... دعنا نفترض أن لدي ابنة و ابن...
تخيل أن لدي 3 بنات و ولد واحد...اذا توفي ابني...
هل تعلم من يأخذ 66%؟ بناتي. اذا بناتي لم يكن موجودات
فحفيداتي,أخواتي من الأب يرثن أكثر من الرجل, لكن كم رجل؟ دعنا نستمع جيدا
في حالات معينة حسنا...
المرأة ترث أكثر من 13 ذكر من العائلة
13 ذكر من العائلة
على سبيل المثال
المرأة في حالة معينة ترث أكثر من الحفيد...
الحفيد,الأب, الجد,الأخ الشقيق,الأخ من الأب, الأخ من الأم,ابن الأخ من الأب,ابن الأخ من الأم
العم(أخ الأب من الأب), العم (أخ الأب من الأم),ابن العم(أخ الأب من الأب), ابن العم (أخ الأب من الأم) و الزوج
هذا كله وفقا للقرآن؟
- وفقا للقرآن في سورة النساء -الحسابات هكذا
-اذن ان لم يكن هناك ابن فالمرأة ترث أكثر من 13 فرد ذكر من افراد العائلة
نعم , هذا مثير للاهتمام